ツイッター使ってる人
(ﾊｲ)
あ、手は挙げれないね
高評価押そう！
あの、実は高評価はすごいモチベ―ションにつながるので
皆さん良かったら是非、高評価押してください！
こんにちは！
はじめしゃちょーです！
皆さん！
ツイッター使ってますでしょうか？
はい、私はじめしゃちょー
重度のツイッターユーザーでございます！
この前、多分ツイッターしてる人なら誰でも…
誰でもってわけでもない…▼※△☆▲※◎★…
ツイッターで僕のことフォローしてる人なら知ってると思うんですけども
「僕コッシ―」
「僕コッシー」という言葉知ってますでしょうか？
まあ、コッシーなんですけどね
「コッシー」っていうキャラクターがいまして
謎のね、「コッシー」っていう
アカウントがあるんですよ！
すごいね、なんか謎めいてて
とりあえず、有名な人に
片っ端から「僕コッシ―」って送ってて
たまに、ディスっぽいことを言っている
「コッシー」というアカウントがあります
あの～、結構僕好きです
結構、結構おもしろい！
ちょっと見てみますか？
「僕コッシ―」非公式アカウントです
ヘッダーから見てこの画素数の粗さが
かなり目立っておりますね
そもそもコッシーって何かと言いますと
ＮＨｋかな？教育テレビの子供たちが見る
まったく意味わからないよね
とりあえずイスの生き物なんですけども
このコッシーのちょっとツイートを見てみますと
あ！俺のもちゃんとリツイートしてくれてるね
「今日はコッシーの日だから
ケーキ１ホール食べるっスー」
うん。
非常に怪しい
このツイートを見ても、わかると思うんですけども
いろんな人にとりあえず片っ端から「僕コッシー」って送っていくだけのアカウントでございます。
で、なんかこれいいなって僕思って
一回マネしたんすよ
マネして「僕コッシー」って呟いたら
急にスイッチ変わって
「はじめしゃちょーを呪いました」とか言い出すし
サボさん(コッシーの仲間)も調子のって
「僕コッシー」とか言ってるし
この集団って一体なんなんだろうって
僕思ったわけですよ
わたくしこの後ノリで、全部のリプライに
「僕コッシー」って返したら
ＵＵＵＭ(しゃちょーの事務所)からツイッターが
乗っ取られたんじゃないかって勘違いされて
電話がかかってきました(ﾍﾟｺﾘ)
というわけで今回は謎のアカウント、
コッシーについて
ちょっと色々調べていこうと思います
できることとしてはとりあえず
相互フォローなんですよね(ﾓｸﾞﾓｸﾞ)
ｗｗｗ
笑っちゃった薄層（？）
こういう感じでね、
なんかこうやたらと絡んでくるんですよ
で、なんとですね、実はですね
先程コッシーにですね、メッセージを送ったんですよ
コッシーに僕のキメ顔の写真をおくってあげたら
なんと！！
返ってきました...！
こちらです
「僕コッシー」
コッシーとコンタクトを計ってこの中身が誰なのか？
というのを調べてみましょう
ひとまず挨拶をしよう
うん
とりあえず、まず返事を
もらうことから考えていきましょうか
なんなんだろうね
すごいところはさ、
ただのコッシーなのに、
フォロワーが5430人いるってとこですよ
さすがに返ってこないすぐには(ﾓｸﾞﾓｸﾞ)
なかなか返ってこないなぁ(からあげクン)
まあ、気長に待ちましょう
(ｺﾞｸｺﾞｸ)
コッシーどうしたっシー？
(焼きそばタイム)
んーー！！！ん！！
きたきたきた！！おおおやば！コッシー！！！
(ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ)
待ってやばい、緊張してきた
どうしよう、コンタクトしてきた
ありが...うわああ！
イス送ってきた！！
寝ちゃってんじゃん！！
眠いのかもしれないですね、コッシーは。
さあ、まず何を聞こうかな？
ちゃんと語尾に「っスー」って付けるんだね
うわあ！
ナッシー送ってきた
えー、まずはこうフレンドリーにね
親しみやすい話題からいきましょう
「コッシーはいつも何時に寝るっスー？」
身近な内容からしっかり攻めていくのがポイントです
うんん(咳払い)
ふっふっふっふ...wwｗ
ははｗｗｗ
5時4分ということは、コッシー(54)だから
5時4分に寝ているらしいです
なんだろう、とりあえず男か女かも
分からないんですけども
とりあえず、ダイレクトメッセージの中でも
彼はコッシーを演技しています
これは多分年齢聞いても54歳って来るんだろうな
「コッシ－は何歳っスー？」
ほらね？
言った通りでしょ？
「僕54」って言って..
wwwww
うん。(真顔)
もう直接的に聞くのがいいのかな？
おお？　おお！おお！
「現実は勉強頑張ってるぐらいの年齢っスー」
学生さんだね！多分
学生さんということが分かりました！！
はい、54でコッシーは分かったわ
コッシーは男なの？女なの？
ちょっとバシッと聞いてみます
「男っスー」
コッシー男なんだー！
色々分ってきましたね
「高校生？！」
ズバリ聞いてみましょう！
果たして何歳くらいなんだろう？
「僕コッシー...」
あー、やっぱりこれは答えずらいのかな？
やっぱさすがにちょっと年齢は
言ってくれなさそうな雰囲気ですね、これは
「ありがとうっスー！塗っておくっスー！」
おー！！喜んでくれた！
よーし！ここから本気出そうか！！
「オレ...もっと君のことが知りたいんだ...」
あーー逃げられたーー
最後になぜコッシーはこのアカウントを
作ったか聞いてみましょう
なんでこのアカウントを作ったんだろうね
🎵♬～(口笛)
お？
「みんなの笑顔が見たいから作ってしまったっスー」
ほぉー！
きれいにまとめましたなぁ
やぁ、でも素敵なことだよ
普通にいいやつだなぁ
あー、君も話せて嬉しかったのね
よかったよかった
逆にコッシーが聞きたいことはないかな？
「はじめしゃちょーに問題を解いてほしいっスー」
おお！！問題？　問題なんだろう？
ｗｗｗ
「5+4=」
コッシー(54)じゃないの...？
ブブブｗｗｗｗ
はい、というわけで謎のアカウント
「コッシー」の正体は
男子学生ということが分かりました
あまり細かいことは聞けなかったんですけども
とりあえず楽しそうにツイッターをやっているんで
よかったらぜひフォローしてあげてください。
コッシーです